I came into filmmaking almost by
accident I'm a composer and trained in
music and I didn't have any particular
interest in the mechanics of filmmaking
I began music lessons pretty early on
trumpet and piano studied music all
through junior high and high school and
became more aware of how music played
such a big part in in films and
particularly foreign films and I got
really into guitar and Bergman and
Fellini in high school and I noticed I
how important you know Meena rota score
is two eight and a half and and that's
just a small example I think the biggest
impression for me was the umbrellas of
Cherbourg and I was sixteen and my
parents showed me that movie and I
watched it all weekend and I just I
thought it was the most terrific thing
ever and I loved the movie and I loved
the music obviously and I act so
although I continued to write music and
study music there was always a thing in
the back of my mind like well it would
be it would be great to make my own
movie for my music
after high school I studied with Philip
Glass and worked for him in New York
City and came back and studied
philosophy at Pasadena City College
because it was then that I was very
interested in Peter Greenaway films
particularly the cook the thief and I
loved how Peter Greenaway used in still
uses of music in its movies and in
particular Michael Nyman scores and I
was just fascinated by how well worked
together and I really was interested in
how directors worked with composers you
know how Woody Allen would choose
big-band music and and that would be or
swing music rather and that would be
very powerful and effective at least at
least for me but I kept writing music I
went to USC and made
in composition there and had a lot of
music lying around not very marketable
music it it I loved it then my friends
liked it and my family liked it and you
know but it was it was it's quirky and
and bold and not bland which is good and
bad so I had all this music lying around
a lot of it was rejected from different
film projects and student projects and
stuff like that brightly so it just
didn't fit I guess so I sort of thought
well maybe I have to write my own movie
for my music to fit and there was a
Jackie Gleason song that really inspired
me to make a movie about LA then I
started writing a script that was for my
for these pieces of music that I that I
had not that I thought it would be easy
but I thought that well there was
nothing I could lose we did a
Kickstarter campaign but the Armen
target was the producer on that film I
found a terrific cinematographer Danny
blinky who's a good friend as well also
found Rob herring who I met through a
friend he went to NYU and he's an actor
and a director and the three of us
really bonded well and Rob directed
nothing in Los Angeles with me it was
really fun being in it shooting it
mostly for me editing it and scoring it
was was really the the post work was the
most fun because I could I knew that if
a scene was going to drag or not be very
you know I didn't have confidence in my
writing in my prose I knew that I could
perhaps save a scene by putting music
into it or something like that you know
because music can always enhance enhance
the moment and stuff so I sort of had
that to fall back on nothing in Los
Angeles came about and we did about a
year of festival circuits including
cynic west which was a very big honor
for us and through that festival
promotion I continued to write music and
scripts at the same time so I would be
up writing scripts and then
downstairs and play piano and write for
a scene and and work on a scene and if I
got too tired or something then I would
go down and and work out the scene
musically somehow and and I enjoyed that
that sort of working at the same thing
you know and so I wrote a second script
showbusiness which is the one we are
talking about now which is available now
on iTunes and Amazon and it's a
screwball comedy Bonnie Hargett produced
this movie and Armen hargrett was the
executive producer and Danny blinky shot
it again most of the music was written
sort of at the same time I was writing
it and editing it so while it was
editing the film I could use pieces of
music that that I thought would work
when I was writing it but then did it so
I would use something from maybe 10
years ago or I would just have to come
up with something else but I liked that
because I I was I knew exactly how I
wanted to seem to be heard sort of and
I've always thought I I never really
wanted to compose music for movies I
wanted to compose movies and I hope that
didn't sound pretentious or I hope it
makes sense I'm not even sure what it
means thank you very much for listening
to this and thank you very much to film
courage for allowing us to be on your
wonderful website and I really
appreciate all the support and watch
show business it's very funny it's short
it doesn't won't take that long
I think it's 80 minutes and it's it's
funny and it's romantic and touching and
has good music to it so thank you very
much